schwer krank auf die intensivstation zu
kommen und dort keine hilfe kein
beatmungsgerät zu erhalten weil es an
ressourcen fehlt diese vorstellung macht
ihm angst konstantin grosch setzt sich
für menschen mit behinderung ein er
fürchtet sie könnten benachteiligt
werden wenn ärztinnen und ärzte im
schlimmsten fall eine triage
priorisieren müssen und nach den
überlebenschancen entscheiden
vielleicht die erfahrung oder auch eine
bestimmte perspektive auf zum beispiel
menschen mit bindungen hat der kann
verleitet werden sehr schnell davon
auszugehen dass diese weniger resilient
sind weniger gesund sind medizinische
nachteile haben und deswegen dann nicht
mehr behandelt werden und das sehen wir
als eine sehr große gefahren eine
gesetzliche regelung zur priorisierung
von patienten gibt es in deutschland
nicht die kliniken orientieren sich an
empfehlungen von fachgesellschaften
danach werden alle patienten die an
intensiv bett brauchen anhand
medizinischer kriterien eingestuft
ausschlaggebend dafür wer behandelt wird
ist die überlebenschance in die
einschätzung fließen ein der aktuelle
gesundheitszustand die allgemeine
gebrechlichkeit und ob schwere
vorerkrankungen die überlebenschance
mindern bei der entscheidung steht
definitiv keine rolle alter sozialer
umstände sozioökonomische umstände
behinderungen und andere faktoren
sondern wir blicken tatsächlich auf den
schweregrad der akuten erkrankung
erstens zweitens auf die medizinische
begleitung stände und die medizinische
begleitung stellen bestände bestimmen
dann die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein
patient eine schwere erkrankung überlebt
in den empfehlungen steht ausdrücklich
eine priorisierung nach behinderung ist
unzulässig doch constantin grosch traut
dem nicht mit acht anderen
beschwerdeführern ist er vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht gezogen um eine
gesetzliche regelung der triage zu
erreichen ich glaube die politik hat die
verpflichtung dazu wenn schon nicht
positive kriterien aufzustellen wann
jemand behandelt wird so doch mindestens
festzuhalten welche kriterien nicht
benutzt werden dürfen um eben personen
von einer behandlung auszuschließen die
verfassungsrichterin und richter werden
entscheiden ob der gesetzgeber tätig
werden muss um diese schwierige frage
der triage zu regeln gefährdete menschen
aber auch ärztinnen und ärzte hoffen auf
klare vorgaben aus karlsruhe
[Musik]